quand on la demandait si vous aviez les
questions pour les chefs vous avez une
question d'erick soulage nous a dit j'ai
48 ans je vote depuis 89
je n'ai jamais vu un gouvernement
remplit ses promesses électorales parce
qu'il est le seul à penser ça le temps
des promesses mais on attend le temps
des réalisations de ces secondes de
patience
cette année beaucoup de promesses très
peu de réalisations à l'université laval
lisa birch coordonne ce qu'on appelle le
pôle y mettre fin au crible toutes les
promesses électorales
[Musique]
ça les smartphones
alors finalement qu'est-ce que le soleil
a brillé sur les promesses 92% selon la
compilation faite par les équipes de les
appeler les meilleurs avant ça il y
avait eu 85 % pour le troisième
gouvernement harper 77% pour le
troisième gouvernement chrétien et 72 %
pour le premier mandat mais il ya des
maisons qui sont quand même très
importants comme par exemple l'objectif
déficit zéro en 2010
la réforme du mode de scrutin où l'arrêt
des subventions pour les combustibles
fossiles
le projet transgreen antenne a été
trouvé dans l'intérêt national
mais même si les promesses sont tenues
est-ce que la réélection est plus facile
[Musique]
et en 2015 ce sont moins de deux
canadiens sur cinq qui ont voté pour les
petites pilules contre le cynisme que
cette capsule et puis j'avais une
question pour mathieu presse écrivez
nous mathieu tentera de vous répondre
avec des études avec quoi des faits
[Musique]